starring elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany as wonder maximoff and vision
respectively
the absolutely titled one division made
its double header debut
on january 15 2021. the series has
quickly established its ascetic as one
of mystery and parody
here's where we are at the end of one
division episode two
for as entertaining as one division is
proving to be it's impossible to ignore
the fact that the show's very existence
seems to go against the current mcu
timeline
vision is supposed to still be dead
after thanos's force for removal
of the mind stone from his head and
wonder certainly wasn't alive in the
1950s or 60s
the first episode of one division
doesn't delve too deeply into what's
really going on but the second up cianti
in a big way
with some hints about what's happening
early on in the episode wonder takes
notice of something sitting in a front
yard bushes
a small toy helicopter with a mysterious
sword emblem on its side
which seems like a clear reference to a
shield-like organization
in the comics called sword later during
wonders meeting with the neighborhood
organizer dutty
a nearby radio begins to speak directly
to her
the odd occurrences don't stop there
following her and vision successful
magic act at the west feud talent show
the two go home but there's no time for
celebration they're alerted by a loud
noise outside prompting them to
investigate it
what they find is a person wearing a
beekeeper suit with bees flying around
him crawling out of a manhole
the man's identity remains unknown but
that same sword looking logo is adorned
on the back of his outfit
implying his connection to the group so
what is sword
in the comics the acronym stands for
sentient world observation
and response department and it sorts of
functions similarly to shield but in
space
recently meanwhile promotional images
for a top's digital trading card said
for one division
have been making the rounds on the
internet and one of them
features a breakdown of the
organization's new acronym
a sentient weapon observation and
response department
sword's motives and their connection to
wonder and vision's reality
will likely be expanded upon in the
coming weeks
midway through one division episode 2
the main action pauses and an
in-universe commercial place
it's one for the rolex-like watch
company strucker whose watches feature
the hydra insignia and name on their
faces
that's a clear reference to marvel's
fictional terrorist organization
determined to take over the world
but what about the name of the watch
company itself it's also an indisputable
nod to established mcu law one of the
leaders of hydra in the films is named
baron wolfgang von strucker
baron strucker hydra's number one thug
it gets even more interesting when you
remember that baron von strucker and
wonder have a history
and not a nice one at that von strucker
first appeared in the mcu in captain
america the winter soldiers mid-credit
scene
where he was shown examining loki's
scepter and a pair of super-powered test
subjects
those subjects none other than pietro
and wonder maximoff in a way
von strucker is directly responsible for
wonder's transformation into the scarlet
witch
and one could even argue that because of
that he's also responsible for
everything that's happened to wonder
post experiment
it's also important to note that in the
commercial we hear the striker watch his
tagline
struck her he'll make time for you
vonstrucker seemingly died in avengers
age of ultron
after ultron murdered him as a message
to the avengers
one would assume that von strucker's
death in the 2015 movie
rules out to return in one division but
vision's supposed to be dead too
there's a very real possibility that
future episodes of one division might
see von strucker appear
making time to visit wonder in her
uncertain reality for some evil reason
the symbol on the back of the
beekeeper's uniform appears to be the
logo for sword but the bees buzzing
around the unidentified man
are a more intriguing mystery in the
marvel comics there's a super villain
named swarm
a former nazi scientist and beekeeper
who combined his consciousness with a
colony of mutant beasts
in the comics he doesn't have much to do
with vision and the scarlet witch but
small details like that have never
stopped the mcu from adapting and
changing other comic characters to suit
its story needs
another potential explanation for the
appearance of the mysterious beekeeper
in one division
is that he's somehow related to aim the
criminal organization also known as
advanced idea mechanics
aim which first showed up in 1966's
strange tales issue 146
was an offshoot of hydra and its leaders
have included the android super adaptoid
monica rapportchini and modok who is set
to appear in his own series on hulu
in the mcu iron man 3 establishes that
aldrich killian created aim
generally while leaders of the
organization dress in business attire
other aim operatives and technicians
sport uniforms and helmets that resemble
beekeepers gear
much like the anonymous man's uniform as
seen at the end of one division's second
episode
on top of that with a reference to hydro
in the strucker watches commercial
it appears that hydra could be
influencing wonder and vision's life in
some way
of course none of that explains a sword
logo on his back
all in all we are buzzing with confusion
early on in one division's first episode
wonder makes it known that she wants
more than anything to fit in with her
envision's new community
she's aware that they're out of place in
the neighborhood and certainly doesn't
want to draw any attention if she can
help it
as if that wasn't difficult enough the
societal pressures of mid 20th century
america quickly start bearing down on
wonder
particularly the expectation that she
envisioned will expand their family
this subplot begins during wonder and
visions dinner with the hearts
as mrs hart unleashes a barrage of
questions upon the two
so where did you two move from
what brought you here how long have you
been married and why don't you have
children yet
one division episode two continues this
plotline in a big way
first alluding to the importance of kids
in their community
through the local talent show containing
the tagline for the children
for the children
thankfully wonders worry quickly
disappears not long after the talent
show wraps up in the episode's closing
moments
she reveals a brand new baby bump
apparently and suddenly quite pregnant
vision appears supportive and wonder is
obviously excited
but given how uncertain this tv
influence dimension is
one has to wonder what's really going on
in the comics wonder and vision do have
children
thomas and william who are twins just
like wonder and her brother pietrowa
with vision being an android though
wanda has to use their superhuman powers
to conceive her sons
which leads to a heartbreaking
revelation in 1989's avengers west coast
issue 51
that they're not actually real that
comic detail should certainly take on
some particular significance
when you think about wonder and vision
reassuring each other that's a sudden
pregnancy
is really happening ultimately however
comics being what they are the two boys
end up being real after all
and go on to become teen superheroes
themselves thomas now going by tommy is
a lightning fast young avengers member
speed
william aka billy is also a member of
the young avengers
a hero called wiccan who possesses
magical and telepathic powers
a striking difference between one
division and the rest of the mcu up to
this point is the use of a black and
white filter
as seen in the first two episodes
however as the latter progresses it
becomes more and more apparent that
colour is on the way
with potentially important implications
wonder is the first character to
encounter non-black and white shades
when she investigates the odd miniature
helicopter that lands on her property
since it sports a bright red and yellow
paint job the toy immediately stands out
to wonder in this monochromatic world
later on after the detonation of the
talking radio dottie's glass shatters in
her hand
resulting in an open wound on her palm
spilling crimson blood from there the
episode remains devoid of color until
the very end to erase seven their
unsettling encounter with the figure in
the beekeeper suit
wander rewinds everything to bring
herself and vision back inside
and the two go on as if the moment never
happened however they noticed that
colour is starting to appear in their
house how this is happening remains a
mystery but it certainly fits with one
division's trend of replicating
television history
as full colour tv became the norm in the
mid-1960s
the fact that wonder herself rewinds
time when she sees something she doesn't
like
seems to be a clear sign that she's much
more in control of what's going on
than even she may realize so the world's
subsequent colorization would probably
be her doing as well
however the possibility remains that she
could be being manipulated too
with seven more episodes in coming one
division will inevitably answer these
burning questions one by one
although it's entirely likely things
will get more convoluted before we see
any resolution
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
one division are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one